build it dry play it Vsauce this is your
home for some of the latest creations
that you need to see this is BDP build
it a portrait of Pippa Middleton sister
of British royal wife Kate made out of
15,000 crumpets and butter with these
butters sculptures
they'll top your crumpet with everything
from Harry Potter to Darth Vader for
dessert check out these jell-o molds
they're part of the 2011 jello mold
competition and include a complete
breakfast
bullets dentures and of course gel Obama
Darth lend built himself an 8 foot tall
r2d2 out of cardboard and duct tape draw
a group of artists painted Berlin by
jumping 500 litres of water-based
environmentally friendly paints on the
road that were then spread by 2000 cars
prepare for Deathly Hallows part-2 with
some epic Harry Potter fan art and
[Music]
here's a few Donkey Kong mashups Star
Wars The Legend of Zelda and adventure
time playing this is what Metallica's
Enter Sandman sounds like when played on
horn
[Music]
we're ready and here's Rob Stein's du
hast without any instruments at all
get sub finally a tribute to portal to
using remixed footage from the game
[Music]
we're not done yet
submit your own B DPS at facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming and as always thanks
for watching